para asignar cargas formales tomás el
número de electrones de valencia en el
átomo libre o el número de electrones de
valencia que el átomo supuestamente
debería tener ya eso le restas el número
de electrones de valencia en el átomo
enlazado o el número de electrones de
valencia que el átomo realmente tiene en
el diagrama asignamos una carga formal
al carbono en la molécula de metano
recuerda que cada enlace consiste en dos
electrones dibujaré los electrones en
estos enlaces porque nos hará más
sencillo asignar una carga formal al
carbono para encontrar la carga formal
del carbono la carga formal es igual al
número de electrones de valencia en el
átomo libre o el número de electrones de
valencia que debería tener el carbono
supuestamente sabemos que el carbono
tiene supuestamente 4 electrones de
valencia puedo escribir un 4 aquí y a
eso le restamos el número de electrones
de valencia que el carbono tiene
realmente
en el diagrama recuerda que cuando
dibujamos nuestros diagramas de puntos
sabíamos que cada enlace como este vino
de un electrón de valencia del hidrógeno
y un electrón de valencia del carbono
podría regresar ese electrón de valencia
al hidrógeno y un electrón de valencia
al carbono dividiremos todos nuestros
enlaces de esta manera dando un electrón
de valencia al hidrógeno y el otro
electrón de valencia al carbono
eso nos hace más sencillo ver que el
carbono tiene 4 electrones de valencia
en nuestros dibujos déjame resaltar los
1234 prestaremos 4 de 4 4 menos 4 es
igual a 0 el carbono tiene una carga
formal de 0 en el metano hagamos este
otro ejemplo de abajo podemos ver que es
diferente porque esta vez tenemos 3
enlaces déjame dibujar los electrones en
esos enlaces y encontremos la carga
formal en el carbono la carga formal en
el carbono es igual al número de
electrones de valencia que el carbono
debería tener supuestamente sabemos que
es 4 y a eso le restamos el número de
electrones de valencia que el carbono
tiene realmente nuestro dibujo dividimos
los electrones en nuestros enlaces igual
que lo hicimos antes
y podemos ver que el carbono sólo tiene
3 electrones alrededor de él esta vez
así que lo resaltar en 1 2 3 4 menos 3
es igual a más 1 el carbono tiene una
carga formal de 1 el carbono
supuestamente debería tener 4 electrones
de valencia pero sólo tiene 3 alrededor
de él perdió uno de sus electrones lo
que le da una carga formal de más 1
déjame continuar dibujando nuevamente
eso aquí en la derecha tenemos el
carbono con
tres enlaces al hidrógeno
y este carbono tiene una carga formal de
más 1 podemos representar eso poniendo
una carga positiva aquí junto al carbono
observa que el carbono no tiene un
octeto de electrones a su alrededor sólo
tiene 6 electrones a su alrededor y eso
de hecho está bien el carbono nunca
podrá exceder un octeto pero está bien
que el carbono tenga menos de 8
electrones
este es un carbono con una carga formal
de más 1 es un carbono cargado
positivamente llamamos a estos carbó
cationes déjame escribir esto aquí abajo
esto es un
y el carbó cationes muy usado en los
mecanismos de química orgánica por lo
que es muy importante entender los
pensamos en el patrón que vemos aquí
tenemos tres enlaces simples alrededor
de este carbono dejame resaltar los
tenemos 1 2 y 3 tenemos 3 en enlaces
simples alrededor de nuestro carbono y
no tenemos pares libres de electrones
alrededor de ese carbono 3 enlaces + 0
pares
libres de electrones nos dará un carbono
cargado positivamente nos dará un kart
vocación cuál es la hibridación de este
carbono cargado positivamente hay 123
enlace sigma y no hay pares libres de
electrones de los vídeos de hibridación
deberías saber que este carbono tiene
hibridación excepto 2 y por esta razón
este carbono tendrá una geometría
tribunal plana
alrededor de él y eso es importante
cuando haces tus mecanismos de química
orgánica es extremadamente importante
entender a los carbó cationes veamos
otros ejemplos de carbó cationes y
analicemos los un poco también
empecemos con el carb ocasión en el
extremo izquierdo el carbono con la
carga formal de más 1 es este del centro
y aquí está enlazado este carbono en
rojo el carbono en rojo está enlazado a
un grupo de h3 aquí arriba al cual
llamamos grupo metilo en química
orgánica el carbono en rojo está
enlazado a otro grupo ch3 aquí y a otro
grupo ch3 aquí el carbono en rojo ya
tiene tres enlaces simples y cero pares
libres de electrones entonces el carbono
en rojo tiene una carga formal de más 1
veamos a este carbó cateo bde aquí
resalta al carbono con la carga formal
de más 1 es este de aquí este carbono en
rojo está unido a este grupo ch 3 en la
izquierda y un grupo ch 3 en la derecha
sólo tenemos dos enlaces aquí sólo
tenemos
enlaces por el momento pero sabemos que
para que ese carbono en rojo tenga una
carga formal de 1 necesitamos 3 enlaces
como el ejemplo de la izquierda en el
ejemplo de la izquierda
aquí tenemos 3 enlaces a ese carbono y
entonces dónde está el último enlace el
último enlace deberá de hacerse con un
hidrógeno así que lo dibujaremos de esta
manera
así que el carbono en rojo está enlazado
a un hidrógeno muchas veces no dibujan
los hidrógenos al hacer estos diagramas
pero es importante entender lo que está
ahí realmente movámonos al siguiente
ejemplo esta vez la carga formal de +1
está en este carbono en rojo y ese
carbono en rojo está directamente
enlazado a un carbono más ese es un
enlace pero sabemos que necesitamos un
total de 3 enlaces por lo que el carbono
en rojo debe tener dos enlaces más y
esos otros dos enlaces deben de ser con
hidrógenos si los dibujamos aquí hay un
enlace al hidrógeno y aquí hay otro
enlace al hidrógeno así que es
importante identificar estos patrones
hagamos otro ejemplo de carga formal
asignemos la carga formal a otro carbono
dibujemos los electrones en nuestros
enlaces
los dibujamos y nuestro objetivo es
encontrar nuestra carga formal en el
carbón o la carga formal en el carbono
es igual al número de electrones de
valencia que el carbono debería tener
supuestamente el cual sabemos que es 4 y
a eso le restamos el número de
electrones de valencia que un carbono
tiene realmente nuestro dibujo dividimos
estos electrones aquí
estos enlaces y esta vez el carbono
tiene un par libre de electrones en él
así que cuántos electrones están
alrededor del carbono en nuestro dibujo
esta vez hay 12
y luego dos más en este par libre 4 y 5
entonces 4 menos 5 nos da una carga
formal de menos 1 por lo que el carbono
supuestamente tiene 4 electrones de
valencia aquí tiene 5 por lo que parece
que ganó un electrón de más lo que le da
una carga formal de menos 1 déjame
continuar dibujando lo nuevamente
tenemos al carbono con tres enlaces al
hidrógeno
y un par libre de electrones en este
carbono una carga formal de menos 1 por
lo que podemos representar eso aquí con
nuestro signo negativo junto a ese
carbono un carbono con una carga
negativa es llamado carbunión
este es un kart
bah
lyon
y analicemos el patrón que tenemos para
nuestro carbón tenemos 1 2 3 enlaces
déjame escribir esto tenemos 3
la sed
y esta vez tenemos un par libre de
electrones tenemos un par libre tres
enlaces más uno
libre de electrones para un carbono eso
nos dará una carga negativa en ese
carbono tendremos un carbón
esto también lo encontramos en
mecanismos de química orgánica así que
analicemos algunos carbones por aquí
abajo empecemos con el carbón en la
izquierda y la carga formal de -1 está
en este carbono que acabo de marcar con
rojo
deberíamos tener tres enlaces y un par
libre de electrones en este carbono
analicémoslo el carbono en rojo está
unido a un ch 3 otro ch 3 y otros ch 3
esos son nuestros tres enlaces y por
supuesto este es el par libre de
electrones
continuamos con el siguiente ejemplo el
carbono con la carga formal de menos 1
es este carbono que acabo de marcar en
rojo el carbono en rojo está
directamente unido a este carbono y
directamente unido a este carbono esos
son dos enlaces necesito un total de
tres enlaces ya tenía un par libre de
electrones aquí está mi par libre de
electrones en este carbono necesito un
enlace más y ese enlace por supuesto
tiene que ser a un hidrógeno así que
puedo dibujar un hidrógeno aquí repito
el hidrógeno normalmente no se dibuja en
los diagramas de puntos pero es
importante saber que el hidrógeno está
ahí finalmente un ejemplo más
la carga formal negativa está en este
carbono y este carbono está directamente
unido a otro carbono ya cuenta con un
par libre de electrones hasta ahora
tenemos un enlace
y un par libre pero tenemos que tener
tres enlaces
porque nos faltan dos enlaces más en ese
carbono en rojo y entonces esos dos
últimos enlaces por supuesto deben ser
dos con el hidrógeno
es importante ser capaces de asignar
cargas formales y hacer los cálculos
matemáticos es importante ser capaz de
hacer estos cálculos
pero eventualmente no tendrás que
continuar haciendo los cálculos
eventualmente podrás mirar un carbono y
saber cuál es la carga formal después de
haber hecho suficientes ejercicios